what do an ancient Greek philosopher and
a 19th century Quaker have in common
with Nobel prize-winning scientists
although they are separated over 2400
years of history each of them
contributed to answering the eternal
question what is stuff made of it was
around 440 BCE that Democritus first
proposed that everything in the world
was made up of tiny particles surrounded
by empty space and he even speculated
that they vary in size and shape
depending on the substance they compose
he called these particles Atomos Greek
for indivisible his ideas were opposed
by the more popular philosophers of his
day Aristotle for instance disagreed
completely stating instead that matter
was made of four elements earth wind
water and fire and most later scientists
followed suit
atoms would remain all but forgotten
until 1808 when a Quaker teacher named
John Dalton sought to challenge
Aristotelian theory whereas democritus's
atom ISM had been purely theoretical
Dalton's showed that common substances
always broke down into the same elements
in the same proportions he concluded
that the various compounds were
combinations of atoms of different
elements each of a particular size and
mass that could neither be created nor
destroyed though he received many honors
for his work as a Quaker Dalton lived
modestly until the end of his days
atomic theory was now accepted by the
scientific community but the next major
advancement would not come until nearly
a century later with a physicist JJ
Thompson's 1897 discovery of the
electron in what we might call the
chocolate chip cookie model of the atom
he showed atoms as uniformly packed
spheres of positive matter filled with
negatively charged electrons Thompson
won a Nobel Prize in 1906 for his
electron discovery but his model of the
atom didn't stick around long this was
because he happened to have some pretty
smart students including a certain
Ernest Rutherford who would become known
as the father of the nuclear age while
studying the effects of x-rays on gases
Rutherford decided to investigate atoms
more closely by shooting small
positively charged alpha particles at a
sheet of gold foil under Thomson's model
the atoms thinly dispersed positive
charge would not be enough to deflect
the particles in any one place the
effect would have been like a bunch of
tennis balls punching through a thin
paper screen but while most of the
particles did pass through some bounced
right back suggesting that the foil was
more like a thick net with a very large
mesh Rutherford concluded that atoms
consisted largely of empty space with
just a few electrons while most of the
mass was concentrated in the center
which he termed the nucleus the alpha
particles passed through the gaps but
bounced back from the dense positively
charged nucleus but the atomic theory
wasn't complete just yet
in 1913 another of Thompson students by
the name of Niels Bohr expanded on
Rutherford's nuclear model drawing on
earlier work by Max Planck and Albert
Einstein he stipulated that electrons
orbit the nucleus at fixed energies and
distances able to jump from one level to
another but not to exist in the space
between Bohr's planetary model took
center stage but soon it too encountered
some complications experiments have
shown that rather than simply being
discrete particles electrons
simultaneously behaved like waves not
being confined to a particular point in
space and in formulating his famous
uncertainty principle Verner Heisenberg
showed it was impossible to determine
both the exact position and speed of
electrons as they moved around an atom
the idea that electrons cannot be
pinpointed but exists within a range of
possible locations gave rise to the
current quantum model of the atom a
fascinating theory with a whole new set
of complexities whose implications have
yet to be fully grasped even though our
understanding of atoms keeps changing
the basic fact of atoms remains so let's
celebrate the triumph of atomic theory
with some fireworks as electrons
circling an atom shift between energy
levels they absorb or release energy in
the form of specific wavelengths of
light resulting in all the marvelous
colors we see and we can imagine
Democritus watching from somewhere
satisfied that over two millennia later
he turned out to have been right all
along
you